Tosun Cole playwright Sinclair Jodie
Whittaker and I play the dr. yassmin can
i mentor Gil I play Yasmin camp and we
are here with BuzzFeed and we're playing
a quiz to determine which doctor and
companion we're a combo
how would your BFFs describe you
enthusiastic clever creative nurturing
ambitious funny I think you're
enthusiastic you're more enthusiastic
she's definitely more fully than
enthusiastic and I think she's the most
enthusiastic what more than the funny or
more than me but will doesn't everywhere
okay put your phone away quite similar
in the sense of four rakat she's
definitely not are you gonna go with
ambition ambition
yeah we've greed that's what you came
with I think she's really fun out there
I think you're really enthusiastic yeah
I'm fine with that okay cool three two
one click yeah
so the next question is choose something
that's cool bowties 3d glasses trench
coats dinosaurs pocket watches and space
its mess oh my god turns cause I'm gonna
go with trench coats can I come here 3d
glasses make me a bit sick no freedom
I'll give them back so it's not really
yours can't believe you both escaped
over dinosaurs and you've come between
3d glasses
I mean space is why I know I know why it
was a bit stupid what we chose because
it says something that's cool we think
out of dinosaurs and Spears at trenches
more practical - OH
which kind of dialect would you want to
fight I'm gonna pitch it makes me
Wolfgang a big blue which decade would
you want to travel to hey I want to do
eggs in it okay so there's a 2015 22
fifties and the 30s
another three
20th century the 30th century that's
what that is I'm saying these I don't
think you say three that don't you say
what's that song alga
I like future so I'm going if you I'm
gonna go to the year 3000 pick a galaxy
the galaxy and then nature's pictures
have really nice are you gonna go to see
the galaxy yeah I need more stars some
over-the-top middle one yeah that's nice
it's like a beach you can see the water
hit in the sand I think I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go top right it looks slightly
like an angel it does yeah I think I'm
gonna go and aired and wings listen Leon
even seen the beach in there do you see
the water yeah that's the one
and I'm gonna go with the second of the
six I'm gonna go third I'm gonna go
second one oh who would you want to team
up with for an adventure we've got
Martha Jones Rory Williams River Song
Craig Owens right in Sinclair and Mickey
Smith everyone loves River Song but
could you imagine me a month away and
leather jackets back-to-back yeah I'm
picking me and Martha Jones and became
Rory picking Mikey pick something
important from doctor the options are a
sonic screwdriver circuit paper this
river songs diary Torchwood a loyal
companion TARDIS well you can't get
anywhere without that can you and we've
got our day still I copied your series
you're easily a one I got at well the
doctor and Clara Oswald and I got exact
listen I've got used to you said okay
this has been really fun take the quiz
yourself and tune in to Doctor Who on
BBC America
[Music]
[Music]
you